hello everyone
welcome to the active inference live
stream it is active stream 9.2
and it is december 1st 2020 so happy
december to
everyone today we are really excited to
have
david um one of the authors of the paper
we're going to be discussing so it will
be just a great discussion today really
looking forward to it
welcome to team com everyone teamcomm is
an experiment in online team
communication
learning and practice related to active
inference
you can find us on our website at
twitter
via email at our youtube channel or our
public key base team
and cubase username this is a recorded
and an archived live stream
so please provide us with feedback so
that we can improve on our work
also all perspectives and backgrounds
are welcome here
and as far as video etiquette for live
stream goes mute if there's noise in
your background
raise your hand so that we can hear from
everybody in the conversation
and let's use respectful speech behavior
just some quick updates on upcoming
active streams
today we are in 9.2 december 1st talking
about
this projective consciousness model
paper and
in the rest of december we'll be talking
about two papers on december 8th and
15th
we'll be in actin 10 on a variational
approach to scripts
and on december 22nd and 29th will be in
active 11 on sophisticated effective
inference so two cool and very
interesting papers that we'll be getting
to
but today in action nine we're still
continuing our discussion of projective
consciousness model
first we're gonna have some
introductions and warm-ups
then we'll go through 9.2 as with
previous times
the projective consciousness model paper
by willowford at all 2018.
and in last conversation in 9.1 and 9.0
we talked about some of the groundwork
and the aims and claims of the paper as
well as going through the abstract and
the roadmap
today especially because we're lucky
enough to have an author on board
we're going to be talking about a few
deeper and auxiliary questions
as well as going through a few key
quotations and talking about maybe some
of the implications
for the paper and then as always we'll
return to the figures and ask what each
figure
is representing or invoking so
cool to have this discussion today and
then different papers in 10 and 11
and then we'll have a whole new suite of
papers in 2021
so get in touch with us if you want to
participate first though
with our nice small group today let's
introduce ourselves
we'll go around and give a short
introduction or a check-in
and then just pass it to somebody who
has not spoken yet
so i'm daniel i'm in california and i
will pass it to adam
uh hi um i'm adam uh adam saffron i'm
in uh bloomington indiana at indiana
university as a
postdoctoral researcher and um
i'm very interested in consciousness and
uh
recently came up with a theory i called
integrated world modeling theory
which has uh a lot of overlap with uh
david's work and
which i find to be really fascinating
and
inspiring so glad to be here
cool let's go to david
hello there i'm david i'm an
associate professor at the university of
geneva switzerland
uh and i'm one of the quarter of this
paper
and somebody work on trying to
model the role of consciousness
including its phenomenal aspects in
let's put it that way generally speaking
biological cybernetics and more
particularly
active in france thank you for having me
here today
cool let's go to sasha welcome sasha
hi everybody my name is sasha i'm
in davis california and i
study developmental neuroscience and how
synapses form in the developing brain
and i'm really interested to be part of
this conversation today
[Music]
cool then we'll go alex and stephen
hi everybody hi i'm alex i'm in moscow
russia
and i'm a researcher in systems
management school
and i visit to steven
hello i'm stephen i'm based in toronto
and i'm doing a practice-based phd in
to participatory theater approaches
and the use of landscapes to explore
themes
and back to daniel i believe that
introduces our
nice group today as far as the warm-up
questions go
we'll just have people raise their hand
whenever they feel like it and
i'll just drop out the first two
questions at the beginning
and they are what interests you about
studying consciousness and what is a way
that we can study it
so both david and adam i know you've
thought a lot about
this maybe one of you two would want to
go first um here
yeah david it's just how did you get to
this uh
area it's a it's just something long
story but
to make it shorter uh let's put it that
way it's
really related to philosophical and
existential equation
and the quest for turning this type of
question into something
scientific but actually i was not that
interested in psychology when
i was younger i wanted to be either an
astrophysicist
or a a conductor you know of orchestra
but
no i did not
interesting it's a different type of
coordination that you're
achieving now uh stephen and then anyone
else who wants to raise their hand
yeah i'm interested in consciousness
it's in a way it's kind of a late
arrival because i
am i always thought that was something
esoteric that i
couldn't really participate in but um
and i've suddenly seen this has started
to come center stage
um and in both this active inference
world
but also being talked about more in in
in the participatory theater environment
so you know what what does it mean to be
consciously aware to have imagination
and what i
think is quite interesting is to try and
move beyond this kind of pan-psychic
um approach that seems to permeate
um a lot of people who actually go there
um
either it's either something that's
ignored and pushed to the side
or it's everywhere and everything in
this pan psychic and what i
am really interested is like how can it
be engaged in a kind of
in terms of how we are reflective or
reflexive
or participatory and what consciousness
means in terms of talking to people who
aren't the same as us
interesting definitely the coming from a
different perspective
is something that's baked into this type
of a framing because yeah
everyone's coming from a different
perspective that's our starting point
that's not our conclusion here and then
there's questions about how we're going
to coordinate
amidst that so we could either have
anyone else raise their hand on these
questions or i'll just put up this
special point two question which is what
is something that you have thought about
differently
after reading the paper or participating
in last week's discussion
and for me it was actually uh biking in
the morning and seeing the moon just
look
massive and thinking about that illusion
in the context of the projection and
what we talked about
last week as well as some other
literature by these authors
so i just thought what might be some
differentiable experiences some little
tests that we could do
that would be able to capture
differences between the projective
model and other models of consciousness
i didn't really have an answer but it
was just something i was thinking about
after our discussion anyone else um
after reading the paper or participating
in the discussion
stephen well one thing that it was
really helpful
this unpacking the diagrams last week
and i noticed that
there was that box for the head on
of of the perspective the consciousness
perspectival consciousness
and it suddenly made me realize that yes
this can bridge more back into the
embodied work
because it i had a discussion about this
paper before with someone who's in
theater and interested in kind of
some of this more kind of esoterical
kind of ways of knowing
but i'm trying to find a way to bridge
it back to
the embodied sort of inactive work and i
sort of by seeing it
in the in their kind of head i suddenly
realized okay it still does come back to
the physicality so that was really
really useful for me
cool cool sasha
um yeah after last week i just began
seeing everything as
um you know more more geometrical
and thinking about um uh people
and their behavior as projections um
kind of
yeah um recognizing that we're always
seeing
just one side or one perspective of
someone's behavior
and um specifically that that geb logo
it just uh that's all i could see
right with the light from the different
sides showing the different letters geb
yeah and we'll come back to geb a little
bit later in this discussion
any other thoughts from the panelists on
these warm-up questions otherwise i'm
sure there'll be a lot to
get into a lot of tangents to go off on
too cool
all right david go ahead
no i will just i just wanted to say that
there would be a lot to
to say about the points and question
that was raised but perhaps we can
not do that now and go through the
stream
and see your questions come about great
so today in this discussion as with our
last two weeks we've been talking about
the projective consciousness model
and phenomenal selfhood which is a paper
in frontiers in psychology december 2018
by willaford at all and thanks david
again for coming out to the stream it's
always
awesome to have the authors the aims and
claims of the paper
we did go through in a previous week but
david just
i'm curious here how do you
present this work or how do you
introduce this topic to different
audiences
who might have familiarity with
different topics like how do you
frame the aims in the claims of the
paper
so lately i've been particularly talking
in
context where you know people come from
artificial intelligence robotics virtual
reality
um uh with you know of course some
more broader philosophical interests
and i generally try to frame it starting
a bit like you did i mean from the
question of
you know what we could call biological
cybernetics and you elaborated on that
term
before and how active inference
for situated autonomous system you know
with
survival challenges uh is an interesting
padding to
understand uh cognition within
biological cybernetics and then i come
to the question of what would be then
the role in that process of
uh what you know we into it as being
consciousness
what we can say about it emphasizing the
big and important challenge of
connecting
let's put it that way for short you know
the
phenomenology of subjective experience
is
some aspect of it with for lack of a
better word functions
why do we perceive and imagine the world
the way and all the earth and ourself in
the world the way we seem to do at a
certain level
and how that actually
how can we make sense of that to
understand
computational in some sense process that
are key
to you know adapt adaptation
uh you know resilience in the context of
biological cybernetics
thanks for that and i think it was
really clear how you
laid out that connection in the paper
basically there's the functions of
consciousness which we'll go through
soon and then there's the uh subjective
aspects
which were captured in the invariance
and the pcm
is like a bridge that's going to be
connecting the subjective invariance of
consciousness
to some of these functional attributes
and so we're kind of going from
point a to point b across a specific
river
and so if we can really be clear about
which sites on the riverbank we're
building from and then be really clear
about what the bridge is
and isn't then we'll have a really good
discussion about consciousness
as opposed to just swirling around and
thinking it does everything and nothing
it's everything and nothing at once and
all these things so any thoughts on the
aims and claims from anyone else
otherwise we'll just go through to the
next section
cool yep we have a lot of questions
coming up so
in uh previous weeks we looked through
the abstract
sentence by sentence just to understand
how the authors were taking the free
energy
energy minimizing approach of active
inference biological cybernetics
and then connecting this to a few other
areas
such as geometry and the embedded
psychology
and uh that was the abstract in the
roadmap
we had the sort of outline of where they
go
they start with an introduction and go
straight to the methodology and then
talk about the two river banks in that
previous metaphor
that we want to connect the
phenomenological invariance of
experience and then the functional
features of consciousness
and then sets up the problem in a way
that hopefully could be
solved so maybe uh david i'm curious
like
in other papers how have you structured
it differently
or this was in 2018 what have you been
um
like wishing that could have been
explained more or where have you
bolstered the theory since then all
right
that's a huge uh question um
so number one uh kenneth williford the
first order of this paper
we expected him to join i don't know if
he will join later
he is a friend of mine and
that i admire for the quality of his
mind
the philosopher and so the structure of
this particular paper
we look at today is i think deeply
informed
by his you know philosophical methods
if you were to read the first paper
we published on the topics in the
journal of biological theoretical
biology sorry
in 2017 you you would find a
two word either but a very different way
of presenting
but they are totally consistent with
each other and uh
in both case you know it's still working
progress so there are still a lot of
questions and
of course we are not claiming that we
explain everything
by far we're trying to restrict
ourselves to things we think we can
frame in
a classical scientific framework
and you know i've been working for years
now in my lab and
we are actually finishing a paper on
that
to integrate in this
in general based on the general
principle of this model
in addition to um visual illusion as we
did recently in the moon illusion paper
that was published in 2020
uh mechanism of effective and social
appraisal and processing in social
perspective taking
based on projected geometry notably but
not only
to model and understand how
artificial agent virtual robotics
as a model of yourself if you wish can
do theory of mind
and how that plays a role in emotion
regulation
adaptation of behavior um and that's
basically what i've been doing and
entrance interestingly
without taking too long and there are uh
some studies from psychophysics that
that show or that you know based on
empirical
data that uh if you are confronted with
an
object or something you you if you feel
is dangerous
like for instance a snake or for some
phobic for instance
intensity of your fear will be a
function of the inverse more or less the
inverse of the distance
of the object and that has been
formalized as
being you know something you can
identify with
an empirical psychophysical law called
stephen's law
with a certain type of exponent and as
it turns out actually uh the projective
geometrical framing just gives you that
naturally it transforms information
probably the size the apparent size of
objects
according under certain constraints to
a law in that is the inverse from the
distance
more or less so you can recover things
that have been documented before and
understand how they may play a role in
appraisal
something i fear when it's closer it's
bigger it takes more of my field of
consciousness if you wish to make it
simpler and so one way of motivating my
behavior of for instance
avoidance is imagining myself further so
the thing is smaller
takes less space and as a result it has
less impact following the very same role
we're
discussing and therefore that will
minimize my free energy and i will
move away and i do that with robots and
things like that
huh very cool yeah i'm imagining this
like
fear is proportional to one over
distance something in that
family of equations uh like a bus that's
a 100 feet away not scary 50 feet away
not scary it's still on the flat part of
the fear curve
and then it gets exponentially higher
when it gets closer to you and takes up
more of your field of vision
so um and then there's also long
distance threats
somebody with a projectile or something
like that and so
that entails a causal model where
somebody who's doing a certain action
might be able to
make an object quite big in your face
very soon but maybe it's not quite there
yet but it could happen rapidly
so that's kind of an interesting take
yeah so the point here is
in along the line of what they were
saying trying to understand
what is or what could be some aspect of
the causal role of consciousness
in things like appraisal and motivation
of behavior
here the point that we make is that
actually the spatial structuring that we
put first
based on projected geometry implies
naturally something about you know
relative size that is consistent with
psychophysics and so it's to say that
you find somehow this con
structuration of space by consciousness
act as a sort of lens
a magnifying device if you think about
it that way
that in virtue of its own geometry
will have an impact that you know can
then be used
for other aspects of motivation and
programming of behavior in the context
of active influence
so maybe we'll get back to this
intermodal
area again but that's the visual field
and
uh not all organisms or humans may have
the visual
field but it's clear that the spatial
objects we visualize them in space
and uh there's something similar though
like if there's a lot of noise in the
background but something is what you're
taking up your field of audio awareness
and so it's like in each of our senses
there can be
a sense like a sensory um expansion
of focus greetings lee just play on
we're just continuing the discussion but
go ahead there david
yes so one of the essential thing
we emphasize is that it's actually not
just the visual field is the it is the
cognition of
space as in form in a multi-modal manner
you know through audio you may recognize
object and all of a sudden you kind of
have an image of sort of
a spatial representation of that object
as if you could see it even though you
don't see it
blind people do that all the time they
have actually perspectival
representation
and they represent object in space based
on other sensory channels there is an
inference that is being made and the
idea is that consciousness
operates at some level of abstractions
once you have actually extracted
information
from different sense modalities and then
they become spatial
objects if you wish with variety of
properties that you put in perspective
in that field of consciousness
and based on which you will operate at
the conscious
level if that makes any sense yep
interesting it's like it's so hard
sometimes to disentangle from the
eyes vision perception debacle
nightmare because we know that we're not
experiencing what
photons hit our retina we know it's a
generative model and you're really
taking it
to the next level and it's like no
you're not even just seeing a generative
model of the visual field you're seeing
this
extremely integra you're quote seeing
integrated field of consciousness and
that
um may depend on your visual abilities
or
your acuity but it also something that's
quite
uh derived from intermodal stimuli and
uh yeah well that's cool stuff let's get
to this
projective geometry idea and we
as non-geometers talked about it a
little bit in previous discussions
and just tried to capture a few of these
points that you said were
differing critically between euclidean
and non-euclidean
geometries so i'm just curious and
perhaps those who are
not familiar with hearing about geometry
and consciousness
in the same sentence just what is it
that brings
geometry to the table and how do we
end up even talking about geometry and
consciousness together
excellent question so first of all a
little disclaimer
i'm not a mathematician even though
since i understood early on that
what i was trying to do required to
think mathematically in a fairly
advanced way i've banged my head to try
to progress
but i'm privileged to work with real and
very you know good mathematicians
so that helps but nevertheless i can
give you
to the limit of my knowledge some info
about it number one i would say
generally speaking
uh you know if experience
one conspicuous aspect of experience of
subjective experience
is a spatial manifestation not all
experience reduced to space
but a big chunk of it is involves it so
it's good from a scientific standpoint
because then it becomes something you
can think about mathematically
a lot of models in let's put it that way
in cognitive science has been based on
information processing sometimes very
formal model like
you know advanced bayesian models or
even active inference
and so there is a lot of emphasis on the
mathematics of
information theory so to speak and here
the notion is that
in order to bridge information
processing if you wish
with aspect of experience as manifested
as a space geometry comes obviously as a
scientific object as a mathematical
object
uh as something you know necessary
so the the the challenge is then to
understand how to articulate information
theory with geometry
in order to have a fuller account of you
know the process
so then now on the uh specifics of
projected geometry it starts from you
know
trying to find some let's call it that
way phenomenological invariant that
most people would agree upon to a
certain extent
considering experience introspectively
it appears that
it's obvious in vision but i claim it's
general in
both perception and imagination that the
way we
quote and quote represent the world
let's not enter into the metaphysics of
a presentation let's use it in a
pragmatic
way here this notion of representation
is in perspective you know obviously
parallel lines
do not appear to us in region as
parallel but they converge
at a certain vanishing point to what
infinity
there is an horizon and it's
three-dimensional it's not like just the
projection of a 3d world of an image we
experience it
with a sense of depth and i argue that's
the same when you imagine yourself
somewhere or
considering something aiming at
something you know the notion of aiming
at is very important in the
phenomenological tradition in philosophy
it's not just about
visual vision it's about spatial aiming
and in all the circumstances
the world is mapped is there a
world that seems to correspond to a
surrounding a world that corresponds to
seeing we remember
or even a totally fantasy world of
things that may never exist
every single time we build a
experience in consciousness the point is
that there is a perspective that is
being taken
with these properties of having an
elusive point of view
somewhat in perception we tend to feel
it
in we feel that we are in the middle of
that space so that the origin is
somewhere in your head perhaps
but that's not uh necessarily the case
uh and that's not something that we can
uh
identify as like the way we could
identify the location of an object in
space it's a music
something that the phenomenologist has
talked about a lot
and it's in perspective so if you take
those two things
an origin of the projection or of the
point of view that is illusive
and a three-dimensional representation
of space that is in perspective
then the only geometry and the
the geometry that account for that is
projective geometry
and here since we say the space is in
three dimension
uh there is this notion of you know left
right up down and
and forward and backward uh it's a
three-dimensional projective space
and then that means that this space is
ruled by the
so-called projective transformation that
are
specific type of transformation that
comes from a group of transformations
that transform perspective into that
space
so for instance you can transform a
point of view
from the point of view i have here
looking at the screen to an imaginary
point of view i would have in a
different position
myself or somebody else and all of that
is naturally governed by that geometry
so then that geometry appears naturally
as
a or if not d candidate to account for
this aspect of phenomenological
experience
and therefore then you can start
thinking about okay how that can play a
role
in the process of active influence
nice thank you for the clear explanation
um
really in that uh little bit the
clearest part
moving forward is this elusive origin
and spatial perspective that we have
if someone can imagine an experience
that doesn't fulfill those two
conditions
then we're already breaking our
assumptions but
if you can that's great it's like write
a paper about it but
given that there's consensus that
there's an elusive origin and a spatial
perspective
we can then say that we're in a family
of uh geometries that are related to
this projective transformation
and so going from there there's other
downstream consequences
so really difficult topics sometimes to
talk about
of course transdisciplinary ideas but i
think it's really
clear how the structure of your argument
is set up stephen
and just just a couple of questions is
is the
is the um the distance as things go away
is that and you feel
less intensity in terms of
the fear or something is that linear or
is that kind of
exponential or is it vary depending on
the space and and i suppose the other
question is
is is this transformation between one
mapping
to the kind of projected geometry is so
it's
it's not like you store it in that form
there's some sort of
action to make it into this projection
yes very good question i'm going to try
to address them to the extent i can
so number number one these experiments
that shows the spatial relationship
between
subjective fear and distance they found
is
a power law with an expression minus one
so basically
it's like the fear decrease
as a function of the inverse one over
the distance so it's not
linear it's not exactly an exponential
it's not linear
and uh as it turns out that's the very
basic
rule of perspective when you want to
build a space in perspective
you divide by your coordinates
x y z coordinates by
a parameter that corresponds to the
distance
along with you are basically projecting
the direction of aiming that can be for
instance in front of you so
basically you find that in that geometry
there is a
similar operations if you wish
as those that are implied by the
the one of a distance models that is
empirically derived
so that's a nonlinear
but it's a very particular type of
non-linearity that is not a
super complex non-linearity that can be
handled computationally
which i guess is important and now
for your the second part of your
question let me
can you can you remind me of it so that
i was just about that
transformation between however the brain
stores it and this
projective phenomenon that we experience
yes so the idea here somewhat
what we have to presuppose if we want to
embrace that type of model
is that there is an unconscious world
model
which is complex which is constantly
updated
that somehow store information
more or less in memory uh in a client
manner
and and that we access that information
by taking perspective on it
so by transforming this sort of
quote-unquote activity and
representation
into a perspective objective
that involved multiple steps and that's
something for instance we develop
the most basic one i would say in our
region paper in which we show
and we how the calibration of a
projective frame in
3d so we set the parameter that defines
the projection
and free energy immunization that's the
ideas free energy minimization
acting on geometry
entails uh illusions such as the moon
illusion
explain the illusions such as enzo
illusion and many other religions we
could not develop in this paper
and that is somewhat the idea is that in
you know sometimes people talk about
access consciousness
you know let's not enter into the
complexity of that debate but
let's say that the hypothesis here is
that in the way we access
information that's in consciousness
there is somewhat a change of
coordinates quote unquote from an
eclidean
representation to a projective one and
that operation
is essential in what makes information
conscious
versus not you know model if that makes
any sense
thanks for the answer let's go to lee
ohio yeah so i was just wondering um
to sort of build on stephen's question
um
if if a fear response is uh
exponentially related to
distance does that hold or is there any
research that shows whether that holds
for a counterfactual
version so i'm thinking here about
phobia or trauma
so if you have a particular experience
you know often in ptsd
those things are replayed um so yeah so
did you
have any thoughts on that or any point
it's really a great question
uh okay
the literature on this on the
the basic experiment is not
huge surprisingly at this and your
and your question is super interesting
indeed because
we would like to demonstrate that even
if you do it in an imaginary way
you recover this type of effect
consistent with the model i'm not aware
of such study but i'm you know i'm doing
so
so much to multidisciplinary work that
the literature i have to cover is vast
and sometimes
i may miss important studies in specific
subfield
but definitely that's you know that
gives us the road map for a great
experiment
in in the in some of the literature i'm
thinking of
um benjamin bergen on simulation he
talks about the difference between um
canonical perspective and i can't
remember the other one but it's
essentially first person
perspective um and the ability to shift
between these so
i just wondered whether it might be
related but i'll be certainly interested
if there's if there's any research that
you're thinking about doing
yeah um david on mute and then go ahead
and then sasha so you want me to speak
now
right oh if you have anything to add
sorry i misunderstood i lost
the screen oh yeah no great point um
and thanks for that question lee um
sasha
um yeah very interesting stuff um
makes me think about um
uh this consciousness and understanding
of um how to interact with your space as
like narrative building
and how that develops over the lifetime
that
like as a child that the things that
you're afraid of are
quite specific and nearby
and as you know as we grow up
we're afraid of much kind of larger but
more distant
things but there's something
you know some transformation we have to
figure out as far as we still have to be
motivated and um afraid of the things
that are
uh either very afraid or very or sorry
very scary
or uh very unlikely and those are still
enough to motivate
um people to avoid them and so i think
that's a really interesting
uh yeah something in there about uh
changing
the scope of your
uh non-euclidean projection let's say
um as you uh grow up
nice sasha and it's kind of like when
you go back to see something scary in
childhood you go oh wait it was only a
six-inch stair that we were jumping off
of
well you're bigger but also you have a
different world view and then just like
in the computational psychiatry realm
we might talk about difference in a
statistical parameter leading to
decreased motivation or
decision making it could be a distortion
of this projection
that results in things being perceived
as dangerously close claustrophobia
people are too close to me or people are
too far away from me
there's so much there with the social
touch as well
um let's go just onto the sort of new
parts of 9.2 and
talk about some of these other slides
and questions we have so last week we
talked about the functional features the
cybernetic features
as well as some of these other theories
threads that were drawn in like the
availability
kind of like a workspace the simulation
theory motivation of action
uh we talked about that last week as
well as the
questions about the phenomenological
invariance
with the emphasis on point one being
that relational phenomenal
intentionality so just pause the video
and look at those if you want more
detail or of course read the paper
but let's go to some feedback from
participants
so one thing that a participant who
couldn't be here today asked
was one thing i'm curious about is
whether they're working
on more complex forms of the model with
higher temporal depth that kind of
speaks to these adult
fears considerations we talked about and
then also this person added
another thing i'm curious about more
philosophically is what do they mean by
now
they have an extended phenomenological
background for the model
which uh suggests that the now would be
extended like an extended now however in
naturalist models which i assumed
uh active inference uh or potentially
artificial intelligence framework based
models are a subset of
time is often modeled and understood as
point-like or as a continuous
variable with points i wonder what the
implications are or what there might be
if they mixed up these two
interpretations of what the now is
the physical and the psychological now
so david what do you think about these
questions from the participant
oh they are great uh i'm gonna try to
address some of it of course and again
it's
there are still a lot of things to
discover and understand
and one of the things we like about
starting with a
mathematical model is that then it's act
as a guide now it's the theory that
tells us
you know where are the problem and where
are the solutions
if you it's a general analogy so i'm
gonna be
i'm gonna i'm going a bit of track but
it's i think useful
uh and without comparing ourselves with
einstein
don't worry we don't have that you know
ambition uh
if you think about a general relativity
once the theory was the mathematical
theory was derived
basically people looked into it and
started thinking uh there's a problem
with this story it tells us that there
should be black holes
right and in fact basically the theory
predicted things that you know nobody
could observe of course before
and very difficult to observe and that
was a consequence of the mathematics
and so that's the idea that we follow
from a scientific standpoint is let's
give us mathematics and see where it
leads us now um one thing i'm curious
about
the first question yes we are working on
more complex form and alluded to that
at the beginning number one this notion
of transformation
of as an investor of distance related to
this literature
is not to say that we appraise
information only that way
it was to show at least to
that type of relation holds an appraisal
and
to some extent or model make sense of it
now about the more complex form
remember the space here the geometry is
one thing but it's embedded into an
active inference framework
with a lot of complex computation
involving higher beliefs and preference
internal model of the body of other
objects
including internal model that's what we
are doing now of
you know beliefs about the beliefs of
others and beliefs about the belief that
other
beliefs are effective beliefs about the
belief that
other believe other have so basically
level six or second order theory of mind
and by actually
imbuing an artificial agent with this
type of
statistical processing and combined with
the
geometry then we can start modeling how
you know inspired from simulation theory
we can put ourselves
in the shoes of others we can try to
imagine what it would feel like
to look at things to observe things to i
might aim at things
as they seems to do including
understanding that they may have
different beliefs and preparations as us
you know the same object may look cool
to us and so
when you get closer it's better but for
them maybe that's something they hate
and when it gets closer you know they
want to run away
so then we have a way of extending the
model very naturally with the same match
with the same general principle
to encompass theory of mind and social
effective perspective taking if you wish
and one interesting thing that we find
is that
when you enable artificial agents with
this type of process
then they and you enable them also to be
influenced by each other
because you may be able to understand
and predict other behavior
but not care about it but if you do then
uh the agents the little robots or the
virtual uh
humans start demand showing
joint attention behavior they start
interacting looking at the same thing
looking at each other to kind of confirm
that they understand what the other
likes
and they constantly put themselves in
the skills of the other and reciprocally
and through this process of you know
projective perspective taking
informed by all these kind of
bayesian-like models and the free energy
minimization
they start showing very complex behavior
including
you know uh we have reproduced in a
non-verbal way the famous celia
and task we know about theory of mind
basically that's two puppets
one of them they are together uh
there is some object of interest in a
basket one of them leave the other take
the object of interest from the basket
and put it in the box and typically it
has
children you know when the other come
back you know where do you think
you know she will go and if you
understand false belief you will say
well
because she believed that the box is
still in the the the object is still in
the basket
she will go to the basket and so we have
modeled a kind of
simulation framework in a non-verbal way
for that
and we show our agents actually exploit
their understanding of
false belief in others to approach uh
disingenuously uh uh object they would
like by you know
um being afraid of being bothered by the
other because now the other has false
belief
the same way we can kind of simulate
some aspect of social anxiety
because anytime you give a you have an
agent that believe that the other agent
doesn't
like it you know uh
then you know playing uh the algorithm
just running the algorithm
anytime the agent imagine itself
approaching the region the other region
that
the agents suppose do not like him
then he puts itself because he practices
he does
a social perspective taking in the shoes
of this
other agent and when he imagined what it
is like for these other regions to see
himself
or itself get closer because of the same
rule we have discussed
he understand that would raise free
energy in the other agents
and since it takes into account the
other agent's opinion that it attributes
to the others
therefore that has its own free energy
as a result it avoid it tend to avoid
approaching the agent
that it believes doesn't like it so you
see you start having very
sophisticated behavior holes through
this
basic uh processing so that's for the
first question sorry it was long i hope
it was not too confusing
any time you have to deal with theory of
mind in particular second order theory
of mind and
talk about belief of that another may
have
about the belief of another etcetera
etcetera and so on it
has become very challenging for the mind
so now
regarding um the other question about
the now
or in the spacious present so in a way
it's a hard question to answer and we
are still working on that
in a way there is the physical time
let's call it that way
which is point like probably that is
involved in the underlying processing
you know whatever it is based on the
brain or
based on some computational algorithm so
there is a there is a timer
and then there is the time as it is
integrated perceived and structure in
consciousness and the idea here is that
because we are doing active inference
constantly anticipating the future to
some extent even a very close
future it can be at different scales
so then we are trying to recover from
that but we are not yet there
the notion of this kind of extended
presence
so that basically at a given time
incident
uh that's not the right at a given
moment
if you wish you not only have this
instantaneous representation of space in
perspective
but you have a process in which uh the
anticipation
drives the next instant in a manner that
is integrated
as a whole so it's very abstract what
i'm saying we're also trying to
understand
how we can put time pressure within
this free energy context and we have
solutions for that
and also how the agents can
dive into their autobiographical memory
under the same process
we are also very interested it's now
it's moving away from that but
it connects to questions that we had
before
2d i would say pathological
transformations
in the sense that here we are talking
about very adaptive behaviors
very tuned to sensorimotor contingencies
and constraints
and uh so that as this embodiment
uh the fact that you know we tend to
have this first person point of view
refer to the representation that we have
of our body in space
that's constrained that embodiment
constraints somewhat
reduce the number of possible projective
transformations
and you know because only some of them
will give you that type of point of view
but if you relax those constraints then
you can get very wild
things that i find are very interesting
to connect with the literature on
psychotrope on mystical experience and
arts
and to give you an example we've not
published on that yet but
one of the things that happens to the
agents is that you know if they
they have the possibility of basically
being freer in the application of the
projective transformation they can use
for instance in the context
in which they are in a desperate world
in the sense that everything they can
think about or do
as an embodied agent will yield
a very high level of free energy there
is no good solution
then one option is to release the
constraint on the projection and when
you do that
in order to minimize free energy the
agent will tend to
basically put their point of view quote
unquote at infinity
what we called the god point of view
which is a bit of a
bad choice of words and so basically
that means that one way of
minimizing free energy for those agents
is
so releasing those normal constraints is
to escape towards infinity so that
basically the world become very very far
and then the structure of the
representation of the world you have
started having very odd symmetries
that may remind us of mandalas or things
like that
so i'm shutting up now wow
a lot of stuff there let's go adam and
then lee and then stephen
um hi can you hear me yep sounds good
um so now one thing i've been struggling
with in terms of
time and consciousness is
whether it's better to think of it as
like
a series of kind of discreet snapshots
or more of a continuous flow i'm
personally leaning more towards um
discrete snapshots and so with respect
to um
uh projective geometric modeling i'm
wondering whether uh the refresh rate
um might be like it's something like
alpha frequencies like 10 times a second
to uh primarily like posterior cortices
getting into the mix of
establishing that uh 40 perspective
um but then where i like and you
mentioned like access consciousness or
where that might start and like the
whole active inferential unfolding
that that might be more at like theta
frequencies like three to four times a
second and then like you might get
something like
uh north of style like uh
spatiotemporal alignments based on like
your enteroceptive states
maybe more at like delta frequencies and
so you might have this like nested
hierarchy of time
scales with a core screening over
events at various uh resolutions but
at the bottom of it though um it seems
like we're like the core of it
is this establishing of a field um
with projective geometric modeling at
the center
and i guess is this are these estimates
i'm wondering
discrete do you think or is it
continuous
that's really a very good question and a
very sound and
interesting hypothesis that you know
with the ceremonial
testing because it's it's a whole
program of research
i've been for longer an
electrophysiologist i work for long and
this stuff i
i don't anymore but you know i'm very
open to pursuing collaborations on that
um i first of all i should say i don't
have an answer to satisfying answer to
that question
i think it's indeed multi-scale
i think that it has the
discrete quote-unquote sharp if not
discrete component
uh which may be perfectly embedded in a
more
at least in the way it manifests itself
a
continuous flow uh but that is
i don't think in and of itself doesn't
compose a
challenge a theoretical challenge it's
just complex but we can
think about how it could be done and we
can also think about how it could be
calibrated based on the type of
biological reason you're talking about
what is more of a theoretical challenge
is this notion of spacious presence
in which somewhere else that's the words
that the phenomenologists like user
would use
we pretend a potential this notion
in the now there is somewhat
us in the center of that now and there
is at the same time a potential
towards the future and somehow there is
simultaneously as a manifold
an experience of the you know here and
now in an experience of the
just after and at the same time there is
still this resonance of
this retention to use gusto's world
world
sorry retention of
of a immediate past so you can think
okay there is an immediate past there is
a
actual present and there is a close
future and then those things are
somewhat bonded together
but the difficulty is to try to think oh
actually you can find a mathematical
expression of a
representation of that in which they are
actually
part of the same whole and not just you
know something you could argue well but
then that means that
you know they are ultimately separate
process so we're still trying to work on
that
see if there is any way of thinking
about that but
we are not yet there cool um
we'll do stephen lee sasha
yeah just building on on the idea that
the projective consciousness can be
released
when things are not certain enough to be
able to know how to
make sense of action in the world it
sort of
ties in with this way that
indigenous approaches are shape-shifting
and they're trying to attune to an
environment which they aren't able to
construct
in the way that we tend to construct and
place ourselves in the center of
so i think there's an interesting thing
as well as there being the risk
it could just be the increasing level of
ambiguity and uncertainty in the world
so that's interesting that you take that
i'm just wondering if there's
as well as the projective thing going
from the self
and maybe to infinity do you think
there's a night like there might be
another process
another type of geometry come in the
other direction
like it could be and that and and this
it sort of shifts towards the
self-centered
and there's an allocentric mechanism as
well
so that's such it's a great question and
attached to
another work that we are pursuing with
mathematician danielle banker
and uh kenneth williford who just told
me unfortunately he could not make it
today
sorry about what sometimes people have
called pre-reflective
self-consciousness it's a bit
along the line of this bizarre sense of
the spacious present but now
it's about self-consciousness in the
sense that
that's what people have called sometimes
the self-consciousness hypothesis
not everybody agrees upon that that
we are always consciousness is always
conscious of itself
that is it's not like a higher order
theory where there is a consciousness
for instance perceptual consciousness of
something and then you reflect upon it
and you know become aware of the fact
that you
are perceiving that the idea is that
it's actually the manifold itself is
such that
you know there is this pre-reflective
reflexive uh relationship
that is fundamental into it and so
philosopher like
sartre i believe
in others i've talked about what you say
that in english the um
the seers seeing or seen this
the sincere if you wish the one we're
seeing is also seen at the same time
as if there was some sort of duality in
which
whenever i have a first person
perspective and i'm looking at the sky
it feels like or there is something in
it that feels like that the sky is
looking back at me
well as it turns out it's a natural
property
of the most you know bizarre
a strange and interesting aspect of
projective geometry which is not just
you know it's a very complex and rich
geometry
and we're trying to work that out thanks
to this mathematician around this
concept of
duality reciprocity uh in which
there is at once
potentially still working out the math
uh
this is the fact that you take this
perspective in implies that
you know the reciprocal perspective and
that you know you look at something and
these things these things look back at
you
uh in your i know it's odd it's bizarre
but you know
it's my my attempt to try to touch upon
what you were talking about
okay lee then sasha adam thanks for all
these cool
questions uh yeah so
um i'm anticipating that i might be
about to ask a stupid question but i'm
i'm going to go ahead anyway so it was
um it was stimulated by
the fact that you were saying that you
were kind of interested in you know like
mystical
uh experiences in relation to projective
geometry
and i was thinking about the um
the meditative experience of of
non-duality
um you know which is um i was wondering
whether you
have come across this and whether you
see it is in any way related to
um projective geometry perhaps
yeah so i used to be i mean i was at
some point i don't know if you know that
person a student of francisco varela
unfortunately passed away during my phd
that's why i moved to the u.s to work
with antonio damasio to finish my phd
and of course with varela who was very
interested in
let's say meditation in a broad sense of
the term
um both for scientific standpoint from a
scientific standpoint as a possible
method to study consciousness but also
more at the personal and
existential level you know i got more
acquainted
to that i practiced it i even studied it
a bit
and i've been for instance involved in a
very nice workshop
in israel and perspective on
consciousness where this type of
tradition
multiple traditions we are meeting
together and we had very interesting
discussions and
thoughts and about about that very nice
group
so um can you try just for me
and for the audience perhaps to specify
the phenomenology
the aspect of the experience you are
describing
the meditator the specific meditation
experience that you are describing this
kind of
unified sure i can try
um so i think in some sense there was
um uh that
prior to a certain point there was an
assumption that there's a separation
between the observer
and the and the observed and
and that starts to break down such that
you kind of
it becomes it becomes once one space for
one to the better
yeah so that i i i think that of course
i'm not saying that's the answer
i'm saying that perhaps that contributes
to that type of state
that connects to the what i was talking
about
of that intrinsic to this the reciprocal
relations that are
embedded into this
geometry i wish the mathematician i
worked with was here
uh there is something like
it's non-trivial that's important a
reciprocity between looking at or aiming
at and being looked at
an ad simultaneously it's like it's not
like necessarily you lose track of where
you know of of the perspectives that you
have
but there is this more
richer uh experience uh that is implied
by this type of geometry
so in that sense in that sense at some
level
you know you you can perfectly conceive
within this geometrically
how you know perspective can be taken
from anywhere
and are all connected to projective
transformation but even deeper
perhaps through notions of dualities
that i
unfortunately could not expand upon
because i would you know totally fail
that's why i need to work with
mathematicians uh that gives you this
sort of
you know unified experience of a
you know sort of some sort of bizarre
panopticon where you
you know you could be anywhere you could
be looking from anywhere and
from your particular perspective and
being looked at that could be you that
could be something
else and that's you know a manifold of
point of view that at the same time is
grounded into a unique
point of view that exists in full
dimension so
i know it's not it sounds bizarre but
that's just the math that's what they
what they are thank you
we have a new visitor but sasha go ahead
then adam um
yeah so just thinking about this whole
time perception
question um whether and i guess it's two
separate things
it's is time discrete or
continuous and the second question is
time perception discrete or continuous
and if it is possible for uh
people to have different you know
spatial uh
understandings or perceptions then um
it's also possible for
people to have uh different perceptions
of time passing
and a different rate of how everything
is happening
and is that um how do we integrate
that or allow for that to happen that
people perceive time
perhaps very differently
well that i don't think in and of itself
is a deeply
difficult conceptual challenge at some
level at least
in the sense that it's not different
if you want to think about it as having
systems that
have internal model of beliefs and
understanding
that you know somebody else may have
different beliefs in my robots in the
example i was giving it was
mainly beliefs about whether or not
an agent likes or dislikes uh something
but uh uh uh you know do you
and all these let's put it that way
let's
be broader in the mechanics of the whole
system there are a lot of parameters
uh that concerns beliefs uh that
concerns
the calibration of projective frames
that can be different from
people to people so i would guess that
it's not a
satisfactory answer i'm sorry but that
could be the same for the
the way the flow of time is
uh structured is construed uh
within consciousness it's to me you know
at some point you are living with
complex systems that have you know
statistical models with a lot of
parameters so it's perfectly logical
that if you
have parameters pertaining to time
consciousness
they could be different from one person
to the other you know at that level of
abstraction i don't think the the
problem is uh
is a an essential challenge in the sense
that oh yeah there is a big paradox that
i cannot resolve
in a consistent manner with mathematical
thinking
but of course there are much deeper
questions than this whole
what we were talking about before this
whole spacious present this kind of
extended experience of experience of the
present of the now
is more difficult to grasp to me yet
cool let's go last comments here from
adam
and then we'll welcome kent
hello can you hear me yep um
so and talking about um this sort of
reciprocity or mutuality of like when
you look and then
looking back at you it started to make
me
wonder about the extent to which
uh projective uh geometric
modeling might be uh inter-subjectively
bootstrapped
and that like it both enables
theory of mind capacities in terms of
giving you this
flexible transformation between
perspectives which would be like at the
heart of like
mentalizing a theory of mind but also
to engage in that i'm wondering if that
helps to
induce the capacity which then feeds
back and
makes you better perspective which then
in a kind of bootstrapping process and
now i'm wondering in terms of like
evolution and development like
when is this starting to arise like you
could in theory think of this happening
like non-inter-subjectively in a way
where it's like
i don't know like a predator sort of
like hunting maybe if i go here
and doing sort of like where do i need
to be to get
like if the organism has like a model of
itself of some degree of temporal depth
and it's trying to do something a little
bit more elaborate trying to like forge
for information well that's like okay i
go here i'll have a different
perspective and this is like influencing
the policy selection
but um in humans it's probably really
heavily
inter-subjectively bootstrapped and so
some thoughts
i i'm not going to make a long comments
to not take too much space but i
find everything you say that i agree
with you i think
actually you write probably so they are
very interesting
stuff in ethology and you know animal
behavior
or even in recent relatively recent
literature that
you know suggests the role of projective
representations into uh the way anymore
uh
try to lure others into
you know either being a mate or you know
being a uh
cool welcome ken you can
[Music]
hi yeah i'm sorry i'm so late all good
morning do you have any uh thing to add
or just feel free to raise your hand
any time okay we'll do cool
well there's a few more slides this was
really a great set of questions by the
participant so that's really
fun topics uh here's some
quotes that i put up there and the part
i wanted to kind of start off with is
the
second half of the second quote on here
which is just uh a system running the
pcm
would more closely approximate the
actual complexity organization and
processing power of human or animal
brains
and this could very well on the author's
view
literally be an artificial consciousness
so
maybe getting into sort of questions
about what does it actually
entail to have the awareness what if you
make a system that has
action and perception and it does a
projective geometry transformation and
it
you know it's doing it because you're
the one who made the robot so i was just
curious to hear about
from the robotics side or from the
mathematical side or from the
neurophenomenological what else is
happening in humans is it evolutionary
is it linguistic etc so i i would like
ken to
to speak because he has a lot to say uh
but
since you asking about robot in that
question is very relevant of course
i will answer as a scientist uh i'm
hiding behind the method the scientific
method
uh and not to avoid the question but to
tell you first that i don't have an
answer to that
fundamental question what i'm trying to
do and that's
i think the only thing science can do
at least as we know it and you can take
the model of physics as a
probability example of that is uh
to try to understand not necessarily why
but
how we do think we do things and that
applies to consciousness to the
phenomenology of consciousness so
what we are modeling here is that
phenomenology
and how it is involved in other process
and so
at the end the only thing i could say
about my robot
in the way they are implemented at this
point you know there is a lot of work
ahead is that at least their behavior
will be governed by principles that are
central to the way consciousness process
information
let's put it that way so it doesn't
imply at all
that those robots are actually conscious
in the sense we
would like to um but at least
uh they can demonstrate how
our consciousness and the principles
that seems to shape our consciousness
uh play a role in our overall the
economy of our behavior etc etc
it doesn't give us a an answer
to why you know this is conscious in the
sense
maybe actually it's with a certain level
of complexity it's sufficient
and maybe ken should speak now and
rebound
on that
well i was going to say this um passage
if uh memory serves we we of course this
is a general
sort of worry that anybody who uh works
on
consciousness thinks about it has
especially if you
are doing anything with um simulations
as uh w
was so we started to think well of
course we don't think that
um the simulations that david has built
are actually contained consciousness uh
you know actually contain conscious
agents
so then you wonder all right you know so
it's not it's not
merely um processing information and
the the way in a way that simulates
what's specified in the model
i guess you could say um it could be
other things as well like uh so in a
sense we
we think okay this is a necessary
condition
for consciousness that you process
information and the way the pcm
outlines um sufficiency
require a certain kind of uh
scale and complexity that that we we're
not we're not certain about yet
so we shouldn't just um assume that any
any kind of situation that
that follows this this model
is just if so facto a conscious being
that's kind of
claiming too much what what else is
involved well we
we don't we don't know but um
it's it seems like uh this is we
we maintain this is necessary for
consciousness
so um the conscious being will
will have this structure what will
process information in this way
um and it for all we know
it could be sort of um
things that we don't we're not going to
be able to reduce
to uh principles
so easily that we'd have to discover
empirically that's the that's the reason
we say here the an aposteriori identity
theory
that's that's the idea that you can't
really say what consciousness is
a priori you have to find out what it is
empirically and at some point you might
find yourself in a situation where you
could say okay
um these suppose we build a lot of
artificial systems
that do this these exhibit
all the behaviors and so on that make it
seem like it you know a conscious being
um
they you know suppose they operate on a
certain scale and a certain
complexity at some point we might be
able to say yeah we think
right here's the sweet spot why exactly
we don't know maybe we will discover
that maybe not
but um on the one hand uh
it seems like it you don't want to be um
shy of saying that the you know from
what we can tell
these are necessary conditions and on
the other you don't want to be
to um you don't want to you don't want
to have a view of the sufficient
conditions
for consciousness that make it quite too
easy
you know so that's awesome
yeah thanks for that response steven
just a really quick comment and then
we'll move on
just just quickly i was just wondering
when you think about projective
consciousness is it like
this is really summing up a particular
type of consciousness
which that we are taking these
projective perspective or
kind of um ways of engaging the world
and there's there's a potential i wonder
if there's a potential for that
to seem like it's more like how
consciousness is because we culturally
have taken that on to be how we
think of the world but this might be
like one
way of taking a view from a more sort of
higher perspective
so we should shall i take this one do we
yes can please do and speak muscle
what's that i think you should speak and
because i have spoken
already a lot and you have a lot of
answers
so i mean our our hypothesis is that
this is not just
of um
you know how we've been enculturated or
uh see if i i've got your question right
i mean our view is that this is this is
a at least a necessary feature of all
consciousness that's that's the claim
so now you could imagine and you could
you could actually wed this kind of uh
view to other theories of consciousness
you could wed it to
you know pan psychism for that matter
you could just say oh no actually
consciousness is something else it's
whatever some fundamental property of
nature
um but this then if you had that sort of
view
this kind of work would still be of
interest because it might
um sketch out how conscious beings
like us or probably you know animals
um how they experience the world and how
they organize how they process
information
all right so but we and of course when
we make it so it's compatible with that
compatible with
um relative consciousness
that's cast at a kind of metaphysical
level i guess um
our view would be something like well
you know suppose
this suppose this type of model
allows us to explain everything that we
we think is pertinent to consciousness
so it allows us to account for whatever
behavioral and cognitive functions
um consciousness carries out and for the
phenomenology of consciousness
um if it if it allowed you to to count
account for those things um then
and you suppose you could identify the
type of structure this is
and the sort of scale and complexity it
needs to be organized on
then to our way of thinking at least as
it comes to the metaphysical issue
we're we have a tendency to think okay
that's just what consciousness is we
we've discovered this
empirically we discovered it aposteriori
there's no need to postulate
any further metaphysics because any any
metaphysical account of consciousness
will actually has the same structure
it's it's something you didn't figure
out a priori really
you just thought okay well here's a
here's an account that would
make sense of the fact that you know say
take pancychism
why is anything consciousness well you
know conscious well
you know if everything is conscious then
it's no mystery that we are
so so that's uh so that's that's an
argument you could make well
you know as you as you probably know
there are all these different um
positions in the philosophy of mind
about the nature of consciousness and
the distribution of consciousness that
in my view they're all kind of
epistemically on a par
none of them are really like you can't
show any of them a priori
you can't demonstrate so um
it seems like it's wide open to you
on the theoretical level to be this kind
of identity theorist
just you when you reach you know when
you have this structure have this level
that you're conscious being that's what
consciousness is we
figure it out empirically and we don't
need to sort of postulate anything else
that said it's totally compatible with
with other views so you could hold that
no this is
much more derived and primitive like
sensing or something is
is is a basic form of con or something
like that
um we we do think though that
so here's one thing that's it's not
exactly a priori but let's say it's a
a strong intuition that a lot of people
have if
if you're conscious of anything that's
going to involve the appearance
of something to so it has this kind of
appearance of
two structure and that's a kind of
spatial
spatial i mean quasi-spatial structure
a proto-geometrical structure um
and and that takes you already kind of
in the direction of of thinking of
consciousness as like a space
and like a projective space in fact
right
um that's not you know this you can't
demonstrate that a priori but it is a
strong intuition that people have so
i'd like to say i think i say in in this
paper going
um you know follow your phenomenological
muse
build your build your models and see
where they take you because we can't
really
determine those things a priori or just
by
banging on the table with our favorite
um
thanks um i i see adam and lee have
their
hands raised but just really quick would
uh especially uh david and uh ken would
would either of you be
okay with staying for like a few minutes
past the hour so we can just continue
talking a few minutes
okay i have
i have a call in about 40 minutes but so
i'm fine oh
beautiful so we'll just um anyone can
depart whenever they need to
and uh otherwise we won't have to come
to a speedy
landing there but we'll go adam and then
lee
oh hello um
i guess i'd like to hear a little bit
more about uh the intuition
for um why it is that existing
simulations
might not be conscious and in terms of
um
what it would actually take to get a
sufficiency um
this is something i've been struggling
with also um the
uh for me like i've been like mostly
coming in from like the neural direction
thing
thinking of like okay what in terms of
neural systems might underlie these
different capacities
and then like what uh how would that be
implemented
um i become a little bit more confused
when i start to think of alternative
implementations so like something like
um
uh projective geometric modeling i'm
wondering if that's
primarily like a posterior mutable
posterior medial cortices and that's
like giving you this sort of
flexible spatial modeling but then this
is like coupled
to like um body maps of like lateral
parietal lobes and that this is part of
like
one um basically synchronous complex
which is
mutually constraining each other as
you're filling in this sort of
joint estimate of the world
and your lived body in relation to it so
basically exactly what you propose
um and so for me it's like when i'm
talking about a biological system
there's a certain grain at which this
calculation
is being established through like a
metastable synchronous complex or
might call it like a non-equilibrium
steady state distribution or
i call it a self-organizing harmonic
mode
but if we're talking about something
like a simulation on a turing machine
that might be doing the geometric
modeling by very different means um
is that an issue is that not an issue
for you uh
just curious to know more thoughts on uh
boundary problems thanks maybe i can
give my thought about that and then can
number one about the functional
neuroanatomy
and the neurodynamical mechanism
that you know may implement the type of
process we are talking about
i think agreeing with you in the paper
we published in 2017 in the journal of
theoretical biology we have at the end a
little figure that kind of
gross functional neural anatomical
hypothesis
and indeed it seems that the posterior
you know
in particular the parietal lobe and to
some extent the posterior mesial
cortex but the posterior mesial cortex
may be more of a is a bridge a hub
towards interaction with other system
but
the parietal lobe and then we could
enter into the detail uh
is certain is probably where this sort
of
project as we call it in the paper
projective geometrical engine
operate and i think the way you you
attempt to make sense of the difference
between
you know something like the model being
processed the way
you describe it into a brain versus into
a turing machine
basically a computer is is perfectly
uh fair and right and maybe indeed
when you do it in the turing-like way
like when i do my simulations with my
humans and robots
you know it doesn't you know entails the
type of uh
experiential aspect that we are trying
to to figure out
of which we are trying to figure out the
cause basically the sufficient condition
and perhaps indeed is a it's a very
different context of
processing the way you describe it and
that is actually key
perhaps not you know it would need more
elaboration of course there's still
explanatory gaps here but
to make that process conscious so
for me it's not a problem it's different
type of of implementation we can use the
turing life to do simulation from which
we can
learn a lot but probably there is
something about
you know the embodied processing with
this type of
whatever the brain is doing and you know
i mean there was scientist
initially and i can i mean we all know
that actually
we know much less about the brain than
you know we pretend to
uh and there are probably great and
important deep fundamentally
still to understand and until we have
understood
the brain in a much deeper way
well we won't be able to conclude in
that question
ken yeah i i can just add that
you know um i mean suppose it
it it sounds a little odd you know from
the
kind of computer science perspective to
think that
say doing performing all these
computations in a massively
parallel way so that um you know
i mean you can imagine you know a tinker
uh computer doing the computations
involved they're taking like
thousands of years or something and you
think okay that's
it's not it's not merely running this
program
right but if you say okay it has to do
with um
massively parallel integrated
computation of these
uh functions um that of course sounds a
bit
like um like strange like why why would
simply being able to do it really fast
or do it in this parallel way make it
make a difference
um but you know
if you're serious identity
then you think well okay we'll just find
out
right it does it does seem really
strange though to think
um that a touring machine
made out of the beer cans and string as
would be consciousness so um so that's
why i i think it's
it's a good idea to leave leave a little
bit of hope here
right
let me just add a little historical note
uh it's not about
uh but it's about von neumann you know
in his seminal paper in
when he was at the bell laboratory i
believe and you derive and explain the
foundation of his
architecture that is now basically a in
implementation of a turing machine
into the computers that we use currently
actually and then you know it become
like oh you know van neumann machine
versus the wet brain
but in fact von neumann in this paper
start from uh
models of artificial neurons the basic
macular can be
neurons to try to figure out how basic
computations such as you know arithmetic
operation could be abstracted
and then he proposed a serial model of
computing
emphasizing that at the time because
they had to use those vacuum tubes to
make those
the equivalent of semiconductor you know
it would be too
too big to build a parallel machine it
would just not be physically practical
you would need like a giant building
just
you know to put enough tubes in there
and so the solution of doing it
in a binary manner and in a kind of
sequential manner it was just a
practical solution
okay but his thinking was broader so you
know maybe there are also deeper aspects
of computations
uh you know we don't understand yet and
that could help us also to make sense of
the experiential
dimension that's an hypothesis
and if i could add one thing that it is
also true that
simply massive complexity
hides i mean it ha it has uh sort of
i don't i don't take this too seriously
but you
you all know the old sort of uh hegelian
idea that um
quantity eventually yields to quality
so you have quantitative changes and you
have enough of them it's
as if it transitions to quality well
there is one way of thinking about that
um in a kind of not not taking the
metaphysics of dialectics
seriously but looking at it uh
epistemically
where very very complicated things can
end up
being in fact this is kind of the way we
are
uh oh somebody brought this up
okay well all right so i'm speaking to
nobody's going to be freaked out if i
start bringing up
hegel no
um anyway the idea is
that particular notion of going from
quantity to quality so just think of
massive complexity and you take a
massively complex system
as a as a as a whole it
can behave in ways that you you have to
understand sort of qualitatively
um you can't i mean you know the they'll
even
some things like chess playing computer
programs to take the
classic example approach your chest pain
playing computer if it's a good program
from the intentional stance
and from dennis term you you
you regard it as you know trying to
attack the crew and so on you don't like
think of
the low level complications going on in
it
to to implement that so
that's all just to say massive
complexity
with the parallel massively parallel
patient it's not totally crazy to think
that that could yield something
that has this kind of form and this kind
of macro structure if you like
that we experience qualitatively
uh the consciousness has it's not
completely crazy to say okay yeah serial
computation couldn't do it but
massively parallel computation could
here's it's no crazier than any theory
of consciousness
i've been um thanks for that i've been
um
that makes a lot of sense to me and i
guess in my own thinking i've been
struggling with like
to what extent i'm dealing with
practical
versus in principle uh
uh issues with respect to like
boundaries and like what it would take
to uh realize consciousness
of like you could say like the massive
parallelism is practically necessary
but is it in principle necessary and
there does seem to be something strange
like
you know church turing uh thesis like in
theory you could
do it with the beer cans and rope and
let it just play out in a really long
time ago and eventually you calculate
the whole
darn thing right but you're just like i
don't know about that
but but why so it would be like well
practically
there might be like a sense for like
okay you need consciousness to both
like inform and be informed by action
perception cycles or something like that
but that's still a practical not
necessarily like an in principle
but then like i guess i've been
wondering like
okay so if it's if we're going to in
principle it
would be like is the computational
objects like
real or not um so like uh
if like like like a simulation versus an
emulation or
things like this so like in like in
with like the recurrent dynamics sort of
like metastable synchronous complexes
model i'm working on uh
even then there's like an issue of like
is this a real thing or not and like
they're dealing with like this issue
with respect to non-equilibrium uh
steady states and the free energy
principle which is like
these um these things are defined as
these like
harmonic modes um but then
their their boundaries are like
um they seem to be
um modeler dependent like like what
um or like in a neural system like do
you ever get like exact synchrony
how much is enough to count um what's
the
uh
what's the time scale at which the thing
actually has its existence
as a particular attracting state and
relative to what and so this is where i
start to
uh yeah this difference between
practical and in in principle issues of
implementation what would actually
and then what would let you say okay
this thing is conscious i'm
i'm still really confused about it
anyways
may i interject do we just say may i
comment on that
yeah i'm gonna go
i don't seem to have a opposition so
i started developing an hypothesis a
while ago
um that i published in you know in a
journal called
advances in neuroscience that actually
died
i don't think it still exists uh
and it was kind of based on a reflection
on my own work and the work of other in
neuroscience and neuropsychology notably
working with
brenda showing that you know
a lot of what we believe has been
critical for cognition in many aspects
of you know
cognition and affective processing in
the brain
like everybody believes now that the
insular cortex is critical for
craving and many aspects of the sense of
self well
i worked with brain damage patients that
basically had no insulin on both sides
like 40 of their brain and nevertheless
you know
except for some deep anterior amnesia
that could be explained by their
whatever uh they were normal so i came
to
actually think that the brain is much
more complex than we think that they are
the way we observe it with the method we
have no imaging or electrophysiology is
very low level
it's not different than putting
thermometers on a microprocessor and
trying to infer
what type of uh operating system is
running
and so i started thinking so maybe there
are you know
layers of abstractions that we haven't
understood in the way the brain process
information
and one analogy that came to my mind i
was very interested in computer science
at the time
is the process of virtualization in
computer science that
is basically a way i mean it's a
simplistic way of explaining it but
a way of creating abstraction layers so
that actually at the
user level of course we are talking
about computer involving user but at the
process
level uh all the details of the hardware
are hidden
you know when to take a very trivial
example that is not a good analogy when
you
use your desktop computer you don't
see the the the machine language you are
not
using word you don't need to program in
assembly language to use your
microsoft word uh interface
so virtualization is actually a process
through which
software or process can be uh
you know abstracted hide the complexity
of the hardware
and also become much more resilient in
the sense that then you can kind of move
things around across servers across you
know different things so
it's not an answer to the question but i
i still have this intuition and belief
that perhaps there is something
analogous
that is bridging the gap to some extent
between you know what we
know and observe of the brain and
subjective experience and more
you know higher order level process that
is analogous to
virtualization that basically the
phenomenal experience of consciousness
is very useful for active inference but
relies on neural mechanisms that
precisely
are designed to hide the
nitty gritty small and complex details
of the hardware and therefore makes it
more you know
usable more practical and of course at
the same time it takes longer because
you need to run many cycles to do that
for instance if you want to simulate a
certain type of microprocessor
over another architectural
microprocessor etc etc
so i think there is something there
about trying to understand this
how the brain may create virtual space
and through virtualization process that
then may help bridge the gap between the
different domain we are talking about
even though it's not sufficient yet in
my mind
it doesn't fully address the problem
cool
just a couple notes to tie together
a little bit of the discussion so we've
heard about a few classic
philosophy of science dichotomies like
necessary insufficient
uh practical and principled from
philosophy and then also like real
versus unreal
seems like to some degree brains would
like
have to
because they're so complex they would
have to create these abstraction layers
just to
like work as control systems just to
work as integrated systems
yeah they would they'd have to
yeah like you'd have to like self-core
screen
just to actually have purchase to do
like hierarchical control
and then once you're doing this um
then you might get potential some like
flexible multiple realizability from
that potentially
or or or or non flexibility too
depending on like
how you did it but
yeah you summarize adam again very good
summary of
in better presentation of my own thing
well you've uh influenced me very
heavily so
uh i don't think that's a coincidence
um yeah one just to bring a few of these
threads together this is all really
interesting stuff
so one is that in complexity we say more
is different
and that's related to this qualitative
to quantitative
more quantitative changes can lead to
qualitative differences through phase
transitions
self-organization just qualitatively
different behavior
strong or weak emergence from just
quantitatively more
and then that's always going to be a
relational question how many grains of
sand are in a heap that's the whole
point is
that's not pretending to be an objective
question it's about
objects but it's not pretending to be a
non-relational
question even though it is about the
world uh and these ideas about which
levels of the system
are available for introspection versus
which art
is related not just to attention schema
theory and attentional assailants
uh saliences from the fep and active
inference
but also a lot of things in gerda
escherbach and so there is a uh
hofstetter citation and a lot of these
ideas have a lot of analogy there
which just shows how in some senses many
of the same
questions are returned to even 40 years
later
so we have to balance out a big
computing hype
from the really quintessential
philosophical questions like
necessary sufficient practical versus
principle
real versus unreal perspectival and
taking that seriously
the relational perspective integrating
topology and geometry so
it's just really this great discussion
and that
the way the paper and actually the
sequence of papers is written is
very clear interfaces and highly
compressed focus
with different metaphysics but just
saying it's neither
uh simply necessary nor sufficient to
have this projected mapping
it's just under condition x and y for
example the
vanishing um you know privilege point
and
all these things we were talking about
it just goes downstream from there so
it's an interesting approach and
as we're hearing from this discussion
that come together
in thinking about these topics so thanks
for like bringing all these
perspectives the tables this cool stuff
um maybe ken can you remember
your reference that you had before on
the glass of later works and get alex
because actually ken has worked a lot on
these questions that actually
contributed to the i'm a strange look
uh strange look book of the glass of
stator by editing a version of it and
he knows later very well so maybe things
to say
cool this is what the this is the
section that where it was one of the
sections where hofstetter was cited
but i'd love to hear about this can it
be great thanks
yeah as well it's just a little bit of
um i guess history about this like um
actually that i met david through um
he and antonio dimaggio were
contributing a paper to a book i was
editing
um and douglas hofstetter also had a
paper in that
book and um you know the papers were
supposed to be like
i don't know 30 pages maybe in hofstede
or turned in 100 pages
so in this kind of typical way so i i
i said well look you know we have to
edit this and he's like you know
um okay but you know be very careful
and so i went through this long process
of editing down his contribution i cut
it in half
and and that eventually became i am a
strange loop
which is uh cited here um but he he was
uh
ultimately uh okay with with my editing
job but
that's yeah so and and in particular i i
what i thought was really
ended up being really nice about um i am
a strange loop
uh the way in which hofstetter
is able to um describe
you know the cause basically the causal
efficacy of um
implement you know of uh implementing
mathematical
forms and so it's it's it's you you know
you ten
at least in philosophy i think think of
mathematics as a totally like abstract
platonic way it doesn't have any causal
powers and so on
and then of course there's the old much
you know there's the aristotelian
tradition which says no no
the forms are actually in the matter
they're implemented in the matter
and but that's that position is not
particularly um
i mean you can find it but it's it's
kind of like it's not the dominant sort
of thumbnail
sketch of this issue in the minds of
most philosophers but
i found hofstetter's book to be really
um really good on that
like you know implementing certain
computational structure
certain ultimately mathematical forms
has
real causal power you know it does
change
uh the system that implements it and and
it's perfectly
legitimate to think of it as a causally
real uh
thing yep one example from hofstetter's
writing that reminded me of today
was when we were talking about whether
it would simply be enough to have a data
processing model that involved a
projective geometrical component would
that be necessary or sufficient for
consciousness
and you're very articulated answer was
about how
actually we know that these are some
sort of uh features
of what we want to be modeling but
they're neither at the necessary nor
sufficient tier
they're things that we're seeing as like
sort of being spun off from some
underlying process that there's still a
lot of mystery around
and so that's like the phonographs um
with the low resolution phonographs in
gerbach it's like
you can make a very limited thing that
does one thing
without error or without some of the
fancy attributes
but then to extrapolate from this less
is different more is different case
it's like well it's not a phonograph
it's a hammer it's like okay it doesn't
play records
yep well it's that kind of a phonograph
that's what it's like to be that kind of
a phonograph
that's what it's like to be a light
switch okay well that's not really the
complexity of system
that we're talking about here which is
the embedded in cultured human
and then that level of complexity the
full featured phonograph
opens itself because of its strange loop
nature to this whole new
universe of recursion and of loops
and of uh self-reflection projection
and then the phase transition or more is
different question is like
how do we get from things that don't
have that strange loop feature to things
that do
but there's nothing that is sort of a
strange loop or is not a strange loop
it's like either it loops back with
sufficient complexity to be strange in
the world
or it's just not strange enough to be as
interesting as these
open-ended infinite generative systems
that we seem to be participating
in adam
and i'm curious about how this interface
is with free energy because i've
i don't i don't think there's been a
hotset or free energy crossover quite
like
this adam hi
um i'm thinking again about what uh
david was mentioning with this sort of
like
reciprocity or mutuality of perspective
of like
seeing and then like looking at
something and then this and being looked
at and
the ways in which um some of these
things might be inter-subjectively
bootstrapped
and i guess i'm wondering um whether
that
puts like a strange loop like right at
the heart
um of this model and i'm also wondering
whether
one of the things that might like
potentially
get you is a um recursion
and like a and a a powerful kind of
reflexivity
which would then you can then start
talking about things like conscious
access
and all sorts of metacognition kind of
like growing out of that potentially
um yeah some thoughts ken you need to
answer that question you know when it
comes to
self-reference and uh non-wealth from
that said theory and all projects etc
you are the one to to address that
okay well so actually that volume that
uh
david contributed to and uh
hofstede are contributing it was it was
a book called the self-representational
approaches to consciousness
um and it's was most of it was written
by you know analytic philosophers and
some
some a couple of phenomenology
phenomenologists but
the that was the theme basically how do
you how you know the people who think
that
like like i long have that consciousness
involves this kind of reflexivity uh
kind of uh
self-awareness that is not just it's not
just introspection
it's a more basic notion of reflexivity
than being able to
attend to yourself or reflect on
yourself and that that
book was uh was about that but i in that
book i kind of looked at ways of
formalizing
this using so the hopster we we
i've asked hofstetter to contribute to
it because
we we thought that's that's right in
line with girdle escher bach and the
notion of
kind of using the notion of meta
mathematics and self-representation
in self reference in um in the meta
mathematical
context as sort of one model for
the kind of self awareness that's
involved in consciousness he of course
that's the strain that's the kind of
quintessential strange loop
for him with respect to consciousness um
but we i uh you know looked at models
using hypersets like sets that contain
themselves
or as members um and
now recently though i mean we we kind of
actually working on that is kind of at
the origin of the the whole
uh project the whole pcm um project
because
um i i moved back to iowa city
at in like 2007
i think that's right and um david was
there um
at uh it's still in the in the he had um
graduated from the neuroscience program
there but he was still
working at the neuroscience program at
iowa and we kind of formed a little
research group
just based on this and this eventually
you know sort of
we we could have discussed geometrical
models a little bit but
but david really had the breakthrough um
with regard to thinking of projective
geometry as the
the the way forward uh somewhere around
2010 or something like that but we um
we long wondered how how can you you
know can you really connect
these two threads this the the
geometrical part
um the projective geometry and um this
notion of
for lack of well to use hofstadter's
term strange strange loopiness
of consciousness um and we
we're actually still working on this so
we we we
we uh we think we're not certain but we
think we
thanks to daniel because that daniel
vincent
um we think we we found a way to connect
these two notions finally
um more clearly um dave do you want to
say a little bit about that
about so how the how the how the pcm
can sort of um make sense of the
this notion of strange loopedness
loopiness strange loopiness
yeah so that was uh really a driving
force indian in
trying to select a a model uh that the
model would
incorporate intrinsically properties
like that so
when i was trying to because i always
had been convinced that you know there
was something geometrical about
nutrition and so we needed to
move from kind of abstract graph theory
and even with this kind of non-well from
that sort of set theory that allows you
these loops etc
into something more phenomenal more
experiential more concrete
so i was looking into kind of possible
geometries that had weird features
beyond this perspective
intuition from which we introduced that
and this projective geometric
geometry under some boundary condition
but actually it's intrinsic to it
as a natural loop
if you wish what i'm going to say is
going to sound very acquired
and it's a kind of qualitative
description of things that needs to be
expressed and formulated vigorously so
sorry for to the mathematician that may
listen if i'm
you know doing it the right way but
basically
when you look at a point at infinity in
front of you
okay so the vanishing point just in
that's the same point that the back of
the point that is actually
the antipodal point in the back
on type of that point so two opposite
points at infinity
in that in projective space are
topologically glued
so that in some sense actually if you
wear
kind of a virtual little creature
moving into the space of consciousness
uh when you reach the point at infinity
you find yourself on the other side of
the space
and uh if you think about
it it's just as if uh actually the
projective space
you know at you know this when you kind
of start messing with the
or considering the plane at infinity and
its topological properties
basically was kind of a sort of
mirror in the sense that basically when
i look in front
that's not the case in a visual
experience obviously but that's in such
that is in the structure of the geometry
i look quite unquote
of myself looking in front from the back
in a kind of reverse way that's a
property that is actually intrinsic to
projective spaces
but that we don't normally see
okay cool stuff here thanks for sharing
all this history
too so just two thoughts one is this
virtualization idea
and in gerda usherbach it's prelude ant
fugue
aunt hillary the ant colony and uh
is it a virtual machine well there's yes
and no in one sense
lower level details are shielded to the
more semantically operative top levels
so that's virtualization for sure
concurrent programming as well
but is it a virtual machine in the sense
that it's a dot
vm that i can run on a different
operating system no
that's not even the ant colony os that's
not a strategy that transfers
so the virtual machine metaphor captures
one aspect perfectly which is that
there's shielding of lower levels of the
quote assembly code
but also there's another feature of
virtual machines that they've come to
mean
in the modern computing environment
which is like reproducible computing
and that's definitely not the case
that's because we have this embodied
inactive
ecological element so that's kind of a
cool uh extension of a hofstetter idea
and then this idea of infinity being on
the other side it's sort of like you
would if your light rays were being bent
around the sphere
or uh whatever shape we're on it would
be
seeing around so that's straight out it
like a laser so that's sort of an
attentional laser
reflected by the higher concentration of
photoreceptors the
increased sensitivity to observations
there but that being the point of
attention
and even meditative practices often
focusing on attentional
points and uh visual rays like that but
it does if you think about the
the ray of light going all the way
around it would be the trajectory you
would look at
to see yourself from the back so very
interesting there and that's related to
our conception of the space of the earth
whereas on a flat plane it would just go
to infinity and then pop through in like
a
piercing way because the space doesn't
bend back on itself adam
sorry yeah so
i'm thinking that you um might be
providing
an additional account of some of the uh
phenomena that uh graziano tries to
describe with the tension schema theory
in terms of um certain intuitions about
the nature of consciousness and
selfhood and a kind of like um awareness
is like a soul-like
ethereal non-material intuition
and so for graziano for him
uh consciousness you know it's this low
dimensional
sketch necessarily reduced
dimensionality for the sake of control
um to have a model that's more
handleable it throws away details and
gives you purchase
but that this like low dimensionality to
it is like the thing that makes you
that if this is your awareness this is
um and your sense of consciousness and
and self coming from this this is part
of certain intuitions about
like immaterial souls and things like
this but
if your perspective inherently involves
this kind of like
strange loop this like difficult
conceivability where it's like you are
both the constant context for everything
the reference point
but you're the one thing that's like
invisible and in this kind of
paradoxical way i'm wondering if even
i'm wondering if that potentially
contributes to similar aspects of
phenomenology
where like certain aspects of kind of
like mystical intuitions
about the self and consciousness some
thoughts
cool question and we're taking it nice
um
in interesting areas david why don't you
can ken could say a lot of things oh
sorry somebody else wanted to talk
nope you or can go ahead okay i'm gonna
i'm gonna just
say something but ken will be able to
better elaborate
there was a a if
a mystic or was a zoterist
named rudolf steiner right ken who
actually uh believe that projective
geometry
uh because of this sort of reciprocity
of perspective when i look at the sky
the sky look back at myself was of
connection to god
now we don't understand you necessarily
but there is a history of mystical and
esoteric traditions
that invokes projective geometry in the
past
in that kind of context right can
yeah so there's there's the steiner uh
tradition which
um one of his students i believe she was
one of the students
olive witchier she wrote a really
introduction to projective geometry um
which uh i highly recommend looking at
it's got wonderful illustrations and um
and they they seem to have been on to
the idea that the projected geometry was
crucial to
uh consciousness and mind um
and but you know they also had a lot of
strange other notions that that
made them seem like cranks you know um
and then there was another
interest in just higher dimensional
geometry
that came from people like um
uh pd ospensky if you've heard of this
this this guy um he um
he was he book called the fourth
dimension and
his his view is that there must be part
of our
selves that we don't have access to in
this
in in the way in which we have access to
three-dimensional objects
which kind of and he thought that would
be in the fourth dimension
it's not clear that he thought that it
was a projective geometrical
structure but um still it's sort of
you know sort of in the ballpark um well
just one quote there is that uh
ospensky who studied under uh gerd jeff
there's some deep esoteric threads and
of course going much
deeper through time alternative ideas
about number
geometry color and of course philosophy
those are in many ways what the uh
less religious at least in the exoteric
sense
of these wisdom traditions so it's very
interesting to see
the geometry spiritual connection
return after who knows maybe never even
a separation
but at the very least in most people's
mind they'd think of it as shapes on a
plane
not about the conceptions of the lower
level
structure of reality or the higher level
structures of reality like the shape the
universe shape of thing shape of
ourselves
so very nice threads and david's a big
fan of uh
what's his name matilda geeker isn't
that right
yeah poet mathematician and romanian
prince
who wrote many books about the
connection
between mathematic aesthetics and
natural forms yes
there are a lot of connections that were
very inspiring to me my father
used to show me his book when i was a
kid and my grandfather was an art
historian and he was also searching
you know interpretation of art forms for
mathematics so there is a long family
tradition that
led me here so i'm sorry but i will have
to leave to another call it was very
very
great i can leave you you can continue
to discuss i was very happy so
uh we'll get in touch and and stay in
touch and i'll see you
great bye-bye guys see you all um move
us
to the end but really uh david and ken
thanks so much
it's like always just great to have the
authors on here to be hearing all this
extra stuff so
the other slides just to you know
visualize them people could screen cap
them
is just a few more quotes to get to that
hegelian dialectic which we actually got
to talk about
um we could have had a few more just
general questions especially
where does active inference fit into
this whole picture and that's in the
cybernetics and how it's carried out but
uh active inference live stream and
whatnot that's always what we want to
think about
and then we just had figure one figure
two figure three
and figure four so those are just things
that we could have talked about maybe
uh in the future or in 2021 we could
have
the moon illusion or a deep dive on one
dimension or another because this was
such a fascinating conversation
so if uh adam or alex or
ken maybe each of you want to have just
a uh
last comment that would be great so
let's um
alex if you want to go first then adam
and then ken or pass no worries if not
okay i'll pass by now thank you alex
um adam any last thoughts
um how is it gonna change what you're
gonna work on or think about
or just
um too many thoughts but one of the
things i'm
uh i'm doing a lot of thinking about
like what neural systems
uh might potentially contribute to
different aspects of uh
visual spatial awareness and geometric
modeling
and um one
issue i'm wondering about um is
the extent to which um
uh at least in its visual nature
it might always the conscious awareness
might always be
um more of a of a 2d projection
and that um things like
three-dimensional
so and things like uh additional depth
and additional dimensions might
involve um
[Music]
the ability to transition between
different points of view in a coherent
way in a way that would imply
a 3d world but where at any given moment
the visual aspect
um is uh actually
uh 2d and potentially without clear
depth
um these are some things i'm wondering
about and
i think it's not incompatible with
projected geometric modeling
it would just be um whether the um
the engine uh you know how distributed
is
like the granularity over which it's
being achieved and so this like coupling
between like a 2d projection screen
and like you know a body map like
adjusting what you ought to see
or something like the posterior
cingulate like saying like okay here's
where you're like
your eyes and your head is so you know
giving putting your perspective in there
and then putting
it it seems like 40 geometry could be
perfectly compatible with this and
but i'm trying to figure out how that
works that was a lot
of rambling but thank you no great
thanks for your participation and this
figure too
i think points out some of what you're
talking about that's a projection onto
the 2d
there's an ambiguous projection on the
left because of the perspective being
ambiguous
and then free energy is invoked just
like a symmetry break that
gives a perspective on which side of the
box one is actually
on given the prior that about how
certain angles
must be reflective of two-dimensional
representations so
yeah ken any um thoughts on that and or
just a last comments uh well just
thank you for uh organizing this and i'm
sorry i couldn't make it for the whole
thing
um and it's really
been a wonderful conversation and i'll
just say the
the next thing we're working on the
daniel and david and i
is a paper trying to relate the
projected geometrical
model uh close or to show how it relates
to notions like strange
strange and pre-reflective
self-consciousness
this kind of more basic type of
self-consciousness than uh
introspection or attention and to show
that you can
you can make sense of that in terms of
the projected geometrical structure
that's the next thing on the agenda
for us cool sounds like a fun
research direction so with all of this
being said
everyone thanks a lot for participating
live
and if you're watching for watching it
too we will
have the follow-up form link is in the
calendar invite if you want to
just provide us some thoughts um any
feedback suggestions and questions are
always welcome
other than that just uh stay in
communication
really appreciate this great
conversation and
some awesome stuff so thanks again
everyone for participating and watching
and we will talk soon so
see you later thank you